- I hear that you found a new passion now.
Golf?
- [Macklemore] Yes.
- You're a golfer.
- Yes.
- I feel like you probably look
fabulous on a golf course.
- You know what?
- Like what do you wear on a golf course?
- Kelly, I'm gonna be honest.
(Alyssa laughing)
- Because it's not great attire.
- No, no, no. But it is now.
- [Kelly] It is now.
Oh, cause you have your own line.
- I started my own
golf clothing company.
- That's so smart.
- [Macklemore] Because I
was going into these stores-
It's very basic and boring.
- It's very basic.
- Yeah.
- Golfers, um, you know they love khaki.
Khakis!
(Alyssa laughs)
- It's just khakis.
And I love a khaki, okay?
- But we're not going
to work in a cubicle.
- No, it's the same,
it was the same outfit.
And I'm like, you know what,
I've always been inspired by
old golf clothing from
like the 70s and the 80s.
- The knickers.
- Yeah, the knickers.
The tartans, the plaids.
- Cute little hats.
- All of that was always so cool to me
as I grew up thrifting.
And so I would have on
these old golf outfits.
So, you know, fast forward a couple years.
Here we are, starting to
play the game of golf.
And I'm like, you know
what, I've loved this.
This is a perfect lane for me
to do something different.
- Oh, hey, wait.
Oh.
- What's happening?
- What is this number?
- My man.
And I brought-
- I'm getting this.
- Yes.
I brought both of you-
- I wanted that one.
- Both you.
- This is you.
- Look at how cute that is.
- I feel like this is you.
- That is so cute.
- What is this?
- I want this one for you.
'cause it goes with your colors.
- This is a lavender,
lavender track suit, okay?
- [Kelly] Wait, can we trade?
- I don't know if lavender's back,
but if it's not, we're
bringing it back. Okay?
- Oh my god.
I love the colors.
Look at her dressing right now.
(Kelly laughing)
- This is amazing.
- With a skirt?
- I am so in right now.
- [Macklemore] Yes.
- I am doing it.
- Oh my god. I love this.
- Yes
- I am doin' it.
- [Alyssa and Kelly] I'm doin' it live.
Doin' it, doin' it live.
- Doin' it live!
- Doin' it live.
- We're doin' it live.
- We're doin' it live!
- Oh god.
This will live in post. I'm
sure this will live in post.
- C'mon.
- My heel, get my heel.
You look incredible right now.
- Nobody look!
Everybody close your eyes.
(audience laughs)
- Okay.
- [Macklemore] Can I look?
- [Kelly] Oh my god.
(audience cheering)
Look at this. Look at this.
(upbeat runway music)
(audience cheers)
- You've gotta model for your...
Don't worry about it. Don't
worry about it. (laughs)
- Yes.
Yes.
- You know what's amazing about you
is you're that hot, that
you're actually pulling off
all of it right now.
- You are amazing.
[Kelly] Oh my gosh.